Hello everybody!
Sorry, sorry for being a little late today.
Um, I actually woke up late.
Oh my gosh, I was supposed to take a nap last night because I had so much preparations to do, uh, for the server and everything and the announcement and stuff like that.
And then I woke up at, um, 11.30 a.m.
Yippee.
Oh, today's not a good day for me because I, I slept wrong too.
So my back is...
I'm sorry.
I took some pain, I took some Tylenol, uh, before the stream.
So I hope it kicks in soon.
Um, but I did not.
I had good sleep.
I woke up.
I woke up and it was like, back hurt.
So, um, and then, you know, I had to take care of dad.
Uh, he's on very strict bed rest, uh, for the next four weeks.
So, uh, to, like, give him his medication and everything.
Uh, I also have to, like, pick him up.
Like, he could walk, but, like, I just don't want to, like, like, you know, um, risk it.
You know, I don't want him to move too much because the doctors were like, oh, make sure he doesn't move too much.
He could, he could still, like, walk to the, to the, to the first walkies as long as it's a very short walkies.
But, um, you know, I want to make sure he's as comfortable as possible.
So, I have to even, like, carry him, I have to carry him to the dog park, put him down, let him pee and poop, and then carry him back, back home and everything.
So, yeah, uh, just, oh my gosh.
And then when I got back, my, my staff, he was like, you gotta do this, you gotta tweet this, you gotta do this, you gotta do, and I was like, remember the dude, I was like, ah!
And the thing is, I also didn't install the shaders and stuff like that.
The shaders and everything for the Minecraft stuff.
So, like, I was, like, trying to figure out how to install shaders.
Like, install the iris and sodium shaders again for my Minecraft thing.
So, like, the thing is, I was so confused because it was, like, it was, like, because I use iris and sodium for my Minecraft, like, modding stuff for shaders and resource packs.
So, and I always have to read the instructions again on how to do it because I have to upgrade it for the, I have to, like, update it for the, you know, 1.2, 1.7 update.
And then, so, I was, like, freaking out because I was, like, why does it say 2.1.8 and 2.1.5?
Where's 2.1.7?
I was so confused.
And I was, like, what happened to it?
So, I was, like, watching YouTube videos and everything and going on Reddit and stuff like that.
Because, like, and you're, like, oh, yeah, it does say 2.1.8, but 2.1.8 encompasses 2.1.7, too.
It includes 2.1.7.
And I'm, like, then I was, like, so confused.
Why doesn't that say that on the installation package?
Why did it jump from 2.1.5 to 2.1.8?
Like, that's...
Oh!
And, um, I was so...
I was so confused because I spent, um, I spent, like, uh, but then, like, the other...
Like, it was, like, 2.1.4, 2.1.5, 2.1.6...
Like, it was, like, 2.1.3, 2.1.4, 2.1.5, 2.1.6.
And there wasn't even 2.1.6 and it was, like, 2.1.8.
And I was, like, what happened to 7?
I...
I was just, like...
What happened...
What happened to 7?
I was...
So, I had to, like...
I was, like, reading...
I had to, like, watch a YouTube video.
I was, like, what is this guy has 2.1.7 on his installation package?
Where's mine?
So apparently they deleted 7 and then like just put... and then just went for 21.8 and it's like, oh, don't worry, it works with 21.7.
But it doesn't say that.
It doesn't say that on like the instructions.
So... I have to find that info on fucking Reddit.
And so anyway, so that's why I'm a little bit late.
Uh... That's why I'm a bit late.
Because I was trying to figure this shit out.
Because I was like, I'm not playing on vanilla.
I'm sorry.
I'm not playing on vanilla like Minecraft.
I... I... I can't.
Like every... You know, like when you... when you use resource packs and then you go back and then like, you know, your eyes start bleeding.
Like... I was like, ah!
I was like, ah!
And so I had to... My eyes!
So I had to like... It's just not the... Yeah, it's not the same.
It's not...
The same.
So I had to... Uh... Two blocks.
I can't believe there's so many blocks in my Minecraft game.
Uh... Um... I... But I'm just so used to using like... Shaders and stuff.
So I had to like get that working.
And after that.
They're like, remember to tweet this?
Remember to tweet that?
Remember to do... Do this?
I was like, okay, okay.
I know I should have done it last night, but I was going to last night if I didn't take a nap, okay?
I'm sorry.
I took a nap.
I was so tired.
But it's okay now.
I got everything done.
Alright, so, um, before we go in more detail about the Minecraft stuff, I do want to talk about a special announcement.
We're doing the announcement right now.
We're gonna do the announcement right now.
Um, so, the special announcement is...
What the f-
Wow!
Yes!
That is our little special announcement!
I am hosting a game jam!
Or you could call it Doki.
Doki jam!
Uh, but yes, um, uh, actually, uh, this is something I've been wanting to do for the longest time.
This was so, like, they worked so fast.
Like, I think, like, they, uh, basically, um, I delegated this to Silent Kuroki, who is a project manager for this project, um, who is also in charge.
Uh, uh, Silent Kuroki is also in charge of the Doki SMP!
So, you know, both announcements just tied in together.
Um, anyway!
So, I contacted Kano, um, who was- who has done, um, the HoloLive game jams in the past.
So, if you've seen those before, um, uh, seen the game jams, uh, they've hosted before in the past, uh, I've seen the work they've done.
Uh, it was- and they also helped work on- they were also the one that did the, uh, the Dragoon, uh, race test.
So, they were also part of that project as well.
And after the Dragoon race test, they, like, they were the ones that helped with, um, coding and developing the game for that.
And, and, um, uh, after that, uh... Oh, does it overlap another big game jam?!
Wait, what game jam is going on?!
I didn't even know that.
What do you mean it overlaps?
Wait, no!
Okay, wait, I actually did not know it overlaps with another game jam.
I didn't...
Oh, oops.
I mean, if there is scheduling problems, maybe we'll extend the deadline and everything.
But if there's no actual big overlap, if there's no actual big overlap, then we'll keep it the date as it is.
Anyway, back on topic.
We got one guide.
Yeah, I'm just...
Maybe move it.
The reason why they chose the dates, because I was asking...
They were ones that proposed the dates for me.
And it was actually supposed to happen earlier, but I pushed it because there's just too many things going on.
And I wanted to...
I wanted, like, more time to...
To space out all these things together.
But they proposed this date because they said that...
They wanted it to be before school.
So before...
Some dragoons have to go back to school, go back to university.
Or, you know...
Not just university.
Maybe high school.
I don't know.
Maybe even middle school.
Maybe I have some talented prodigies in my chat right now.
But yes, it starts on August 2nd.
And you have two weeks to make a game with a bunch of other dragoons.
So, not elementary.
If you're in elementary, you're not allowed to watch me because you're not over the age of 13.
And technically, you're not allowed to, like, chat in my channel if you're not over 13.
Anyway.
So, for those who don't know what a game jam is...
Basically, it's a bunch of people coming together to make a game within a time limit.
So, a bunch of developers, programmers, coders...
I mean, that's all in their developers.
I don't know.
I said developers, like, three times, apparently.
Artists, writers, project managers, all coming together to try and make a game from scratch.
And it starts on August 2nd.
Like I said, after I worked with Kano with the dragon horse race test, I saw, like, his portfolio and saw that he has organized the Halive game gems, the fan game gems.
And I figured this was something I actually really wanted to do for the longest time.
I've participated in game gems before in the past when I was in university.
As an artist.
And, like, semi-coder.
So, this was something that I really wanted to do.
Because I love seeing...
It's really fun.
Being in a game gem is incredibly fun.
And especially getting to work with everybody together.
Try and make something out of nothing.
And, um...
Uh...
And...
Oh, the link...
For someone that's, like, saying the link for the instructions video is broken.
Um...
Are you talking about the Minecraft server?
You have to be a member to be able to see the link.
So, that's why...
If you can't access the link regarding the Minecraft server, it's...
It's only because you...
You need to have...
Like, you need to be a member.
Um...
Anyway...
Uh...
Yeah, because the server is for members only.
But I'll be streaming all the...
I'll be streaming the server as a public stream.
Anyway, back to the game gem.
Sorry.
I'm, like, going back and forth.
Uh...
Um...
But yes, let me tweet it out real quick.
The instructions will be on the Ichio page.
So...
Uh...
Can...
Can silent croaky up...
I don't know if they posted the...
The published the Ichio yet.
Let me check real quick.
Yes!
It has been published.
Um...
I...
Trying to remember if...
There is a community discord that has been set up for the game jam.
So let me tweet it out real quick.
Yay!
Boop!
Alright.
So...
For anyone that wants to know more details about the game jam.
For those who want to join the discord server.
The community server.
Uh...
To form your teams and everything.
It is all in...
Um...
The Ichio page.
But yes.
There will be prizes.
Uh...
Um...
And everyone that participates will receive something.
I can't say what it is yet because...
Uh...
We're still trying to finalize the details regarding the...
It's a physical prize.
Maybe.
It could...
There is a potential that it could be a physical prize.
But like...
You have an option to like...
Not take the physical prize.
And get like a...
Um...
Get like...
Like exchange it for like currency within my store.
Like...
Within the Doki merch store.
Uh...
But...
Like...
The first option is a physical prize.
But like...
If something...
You know...
You want privacy concerns and stuff like that.
Um...
Obviously we want re-handling the address.
I won't DC any addresses and everything...
And anything.
But...
You can also exchange it for a...
A non-physical prize.
Which...
Might end up turning into a physical prize.
Um...
But that's where like...
Everyone who participates at least gets something.
Um...
Uh...
But yes.
First place is 2,000.
Second place is 1,000.
Um...
Split amongst your team by the way.
This is split.
Not each person.
But it will be split amongst your team.
And then third place is...
Five hundred dollars.
So...
Um...
And...
Uh...
At the end of the game jam.
Of course I'll be playing...
Uh...
Some of these games on stream.
And everything.
And then obviously...
You dragoons will also be able to play these games on stream.
And...
Um...
And then we're...
Uh...
Me and my team will figure out the winners!
Ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha!
Uh...
But yes.
It's very exciting.
I'm super...
Excited about this project.
Huge shout out to everybody that worked on it.
It was mostly like...
The entire team.
Like...
Cause I said I delegated this.
I delegated this to Silent Kuroki.
So this was basically their baby for this project.
Um...
All I did was just like...
Uh...
Basically approve stuff.
Or if I had any feedback or anything.
Um...
Like I was like...
You know...
At the end of the...
The check process...
Like the...
Um...
The end of like the final checks and everything.
For their decisions that they wanna make.
So...
Huge shout out to the entire team.
Um...
For working on this.
And I'm super excited for the Doki Jam.
I'm really, really excited.
I cannot wait to see...
Um...
To see like all the hard work.
And...
From all you dragons.
In doing this.
And play all your games and everything.
Like I said...
It's something I've...
Always wanted to do for the longest time.
So I'm very, very happy to...
Have this project come into fruition.
And...
Uh...
To try out your games.
But yes...
Um...
If there's nothing...
If we feel like there's no actual big obstacle.
In terms of like the dates.
We'll just keep it as it is.
So July...
August...
It starts at August 2nd.
And then...
Two week timer.
Tick tock.
So you have until August 2nd.
To form your team.
Um...
Anyway...
Ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba.
Alright.
The other announcement.
Well as you guys know.
The Doki SMP was the other announcement.
Before I begin.
I wanna give a...
Huge shout out to...
Um...
To...
Uh...
Our sponsor.
So every future Minecraft stream.
On the Doki SMP.
Is sponsored.
Um...
By...
Uh...
By CloudNord.
Who is a Minecraft...
Who...
I mean, not just Minecraft, but they host... Basically, they are a service for providing servers and stuff.
And they were the ones that provided our Minecraft server.
And our agreement was that I will be streaming Minecraft at least once every month.
So, at least once every month, I will be on the Doki SMP server.
So, I will be here streaming... Like, I will be streaming it publicly and everything.
And, you know, playing Minecraft Wiki Dragoons.
So, they are our sponsor and the host of the entire SMP.
So, for those who don't know about the Dragoo Minecraft server, there was a first attempt at the server.
And it failed.
I will own up to it.
It failed.
Because I was not expecting how much work it was overall.
And obviously, I had a lot of stuff going on around that time.
So, I couldn't keep up with it and everything.
Because it was just me working on...
It was, like, not just me, but, like, I was the main point of contact.
And, like, I didn't really...
I didn't really have, like, another staff at that time to help me with this.
The best my manager could do, my manager was in the group chat, was just poke me to be, like, respond to this, respond to that.
But, obviously, like, it was very hard to get a hold of me at that time.
Because there's so many things going on behind the scenes that I couldn't...
I couldn't really do much on that, like, with that server.
And because of that, though, there was a whole issue with whitelisting and stuff like that.
Because I had to do it...
Me and the mods had to do it by hand because we didn't have a proper system in place regarding whitelisting people as well as, like, removing people from the whitelist.
Because this is the server.
This server was only for members, but we publicly streamed the server due to the Minecraft TOS and stuff like that.
Because, you know, like, I don't know if you guys know this, but in the Minecraft TOS, you're not allowed to have, like, paywall streams regarding Minecraft.
So, like, you know, that was going on and everything.
So, it was very hard to figure out how to properly do a... make a system for it for the dragoons who are, you know, who are on the server.
So, this took a very long time to figure out.
Throughout that, our old development team had to back out from this project because they had... they wanted to pivot to something else.
And, obviously, that put a huge wrench, uh... huge wrench in our plans because that delayed the grand reopening because we had a lot of stuff we had to fix.
We had a lot of things to do on the server.
So, because of that, we had to, um, we had to, like, hire a new team and, uh, you know, I don't know if you guys remember seeing a tweet about me trying to find a...
Uh, a Minecraft, like, administer or someone who knows how to, like, do...
I don't even remember.
That tweet was drafted by SilentCrokey in terms of, like, what they needed.
And I don't even remember what they needed.
I just... it was, like, some admin developer for Minecraft.
Like, I don't remember what tweet I made.
I...
Like, oh, yeah, the system admin.
And, yeah, yeah, so, um, so, yeah, so we had to hire a new system admin, we had to hire new developers, and stuff like that, and everything, um, for all of that.
So, like I said, the whole Doki SMP thing took a very long time to rehaul, to restructure, to, like, because we also had to rewrite the plugins and everything to work for the newest Minecraft updates.
So, um, obviously, a lot of stuff had to be rewritten and, um, redone for the newest Minecraft update, because the plugin, um, the plugin didn't work, uh, for, like, newer servers, and there were some issues with some of the plugins.
Um, but in the end, after around, like, I guess, like, half a year, slash half, almost a year, slash half a year, we finally are able to do a grand reopening of the Doki SMP.
Um, and, we have a new system in place for whitelisting, um, and, because it was that, basically, I do have an instruction for everyone.
If you are a member, you have to be a member for this, um, but, but, but, I, I even made, like, an instructions PNG.
Alright, so, you click on the setting cog wheel, right there, and then, you click connections.
And then, in connections, you go here, with the profile here, you go here, and then you click your YouTube thing.
And then, you connect your YouTube, your YouTube account.
That is membered, by the way.
That is membered, um, because some people might connect to a different YouTube channel.
But it has to be a membered, a membered, uh, YouTube channel for this channel.
And after that, you will see this pop up.
And it's called the Doki Minecraft SMP.
And you just click join.
Um, after, after all, after you click join, it should automatically, um, put you in the Discord server.
And from there, they will give you your, the, the Minecraft IP.
I'm not showing the Minecraft IP yet, because I'm not in.
I won't be in, I won't be the first one on the server.
So, the moment I am on the server, the, the Discord server will reveal the Minecraft IP for everyone, um, that's a member.
And in the, this, in the Doki SMP server.
Uh, um, um, so yes, this is, this is, uh, members only, uh, to play on the server.
And, uh, it already has, we just can't join.
Wait, oh, oh, the IP is in the Discord.
Oh, okay, they revealed the IP.
All right, cool.
All right, that's cool.
Okay, apparently you guys just aren't allowed in yet.
All right, so the moment, the floodgates will open the moment I'm in the server.
Anyway, anyway, what was I saying?
Uh, we have a new system in place now.
Um, the instruction, basically, we have a whitelist system.
We have a bot that does the whitelisting for us.
That was programmed.
And, um, the moment you're unmembered, you're kicked out.
So, the moment you're unmembered, you have lost your right to enter the server.
You're still in the Discord.
But, uh, you are, you'll be kicked out of the server, the Minecraft server.
So, yeah, exiled.
Until you're remembered.
When you're remembered, then the bot puts you back in.
Yeah, it's like, you know, you get fired and you have to, like, like, hand in, hand in everything.
Like, hand in your card.
So, remember me.
Um, um, so, the, the moment you're, you're remembered, remember, the moment you're remembered, the whitelist will acknowledge it.
And, like, you're let back into the Minecraft server.
Um, but, yeah, like I said, huge shout-out to the team, um, for working really hard on this.
This server is made for you guys.
There will be a separate fund.
Um, more details will be on the Discord server.
But, there will be a separate fund established to pay for the devs.
And, uh, the devs and maybe, like, artists.
We're going to put, like, you know, extra cosmetics or resource packs in there.
Um, so, and developing more plugins or, like, more structures in there.
So, there will be a separate fund there for you dragoons.
And I won't be able to touch this fund.
And it will go directly towards the developers and, um, um, and any of the staff or, like, mods that are working on the server.
Um, and you guys can decide what you want to want for the server.
Like, you guys can, like, you know, give suggestions and everything.
Like, what kind of plugins you want.
What kind of quality of life changes you want for this.
Um, and, uh, like, you know, ideas you want to do.
Events you want to host on there and stuff like that.
So, we're going to have, make it more, so that's more personalized to you dragoons.
And make, make it fun for you guys.
Um, um, does it have fancy cool plugins?
Right now, it's mostly quality of life stuff.
Um, there, there is, like, I don't know if the stadium has been implemented.
Um, or anything, but there are, like, some quality of life plugins in there.
Uh, and you don't have to download anything on your own end.
You just have, basically, you just have to log in and you should be fine.
Like, and, like, the server will basically install it, uh, for you.
Um, um, but yeah, this whole, uh, this whole journey was a very big learning experience for me.
But now we have a whole new team now and a support staff, too, for the Doki SMP.
And I hope that, you know, um, it, uh, I hope you guys enjoy your time.
Um, and, like, bond with other dragoons and stuff.
And make new friends and everything.
And, you know, have wars if you want.
Like, I don't know, have another civil war.
That's fine by me.
Just, I just want you guys to have a good time.
Uh, but now we have a huge, uh, better support system to, um, to facilitate everything.
And for you guys to, like, you know, um, much more, much more organized.
Not like last time where it was, like, pure anarchy.
We, uh, we actually have a support staff for it.
Um, now for those who are wondering about the old SMP.
What about 1.0?
You can still access 1.0 on the main server.
Um, you just have to...
It's just, it's just as a spectator.
You can look through...
It's like a museum tour.
So, you're like, um, you're like, I don't know, you're in Greece looking at Pompeii.
Sorry, is it in Greece or in Rome?
I don't, I don't know my geography.
It's like a history museum.
Uh, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
Um, but, uh, basically, you can, as a spectator.
Oh, it's in Italy.
You know what?
Three out of...
Three...
I got the, I got the continent right.
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
At least I knew it was in Europe, you know?
I was close.
I was... I was close, guys.
That's a... yikes.
It's a really low bar.
It's like, you know, going to Europe.
I should just say, it's like going to Europe to see Pompeii.
So, you can, as a... you can, like, fly around the old SMP and look at, like, relics of the past, you know.
And see what the old builds were.
So, in this new... in the new Minecraft server, you can claim lands, as always.
There's a claiming feature.
And...
We will be going... logging in and claiming our land to create DokiTown again.
What else?
Oh, yeah.
And you can join a faction.
There will be more stuff.
We will plan...
I have plans for more things to do regarding the faction thing.
So, you can either be a long goon, a chonky goon, an egg goon, or a regular drag goon.
So, you can claim a faction.
There is group chats, too.
If you're in a group, you can group up with other drag goons.
And there's, like, specific group chats for... for you guys.
So, the chatting system isn't, like, a huge mess.
I think that's all there is to say about the grand reopening of the Doki SMP.
Like I said, we are... we have big plans for more stuff to add on the server in the future.
Okay.
But for now, let's just get started.
For those who want to join the server, like I said, you have to be a member to access the Dragoon server.
For those who are like, how do I get in?
All right.
Let me put some music on before we start this.
Because I don't want... need some tunes.
All right.
Sound guy, if you're here, we need your help.
Make sure everything will be okay.
All right.
Let's get in.
Here you go.
Let me in.
All right.
There you go.
So, I believe this is the... this is the only PvP save zone.
So, this is the town hall.
We will... I'm planning on remaking this town hall to make it more like a saloon.
Like a west... an actual western town.
Um...
So... so you can see here.
This is how you claim.
But like, there's a selection tool for claiming.
What the fuck?
Oh, yeah.
Oh, my skin is still a...
I forgot.
I forgot that.
Um...
My... my...
Are these both...
This?
Are they both the...
Oh, my God.
They're both the same thing.
They're...
They're both the same.
I don't know why I have that.
Um...
But...
Why is Mehdi in here already?
What the...
How did he get in?
Okay.
I forgot...
Oh, whatever.
It's fine.
I'm committed.
I'm just giving me a...
I'm blending in.
I'm...
I'm camouflaged in.
All right.
Admins!
Let them in!
He said...
Let...
Oh, okay.
They shut down.
Okay.
I...
And...
Um...
And I was like, how is there a Dragoon in here already?
Open the gates!
Okay.
All right.
Give me a sec.
Am I in?
Okay.
Wait.
Did I...
Did I whitelist myself?
Yeah, I did.
Okay.
I was gonna say...
I was like, why am I required to whitelist myself?
What the...
Oh, my God.
Oh, my...
Where am I?
Okay.
Now.
All right.
Let them in!
That's right!
I was gonna say...
Do I...
Am I required to let my...
Like, whitelist myself in?
Oh, nice.
Let them all in!
Yeah, I was gonna say, that lightning was fucking...
Metal.
That was looking metal as fuck.
I was like, holy shit.
That's hardcore.
All right.
Bring the game up a little bit.
Like, no problem.
All right.
All right!
Get in here, dragons!
Everybody, get in!
Pick your faction!
That's right!
Oh, my God!
All right.
So, this is one of the mods.
Don't piss him off, because he will kill you.
So, this is...
I think some of you guys might remember Silent Thanos.
He will kill you if you piss him off.
He's the one...
He's one of the more like...
Oh, I was so worried.
He is the no-nonsense mod.
He is the...
He is the one where you do not fuck with on the server, from what I've heard.
It's not...
He is not friendly.
He is the...
The hello, everybody!
Yes!
If you were in the server before, you might have some...
You might have your old gear.
So, everyone that like had stuff in their inventory actually sort of kept it.
Uh...
Um...
But...
Everything else is wiped up.
Does it have proximity?
If you have...
If you have the...
The...
What is it?
The mod with the voice chat on?
Um...
We do have the voice chat mod on.
So, uh...
If you already...
Because like that, you need to install it on your own end as well.
So...
Um...
If you already have that on, then there is proximity chat.
I don't have it on because, like, I want to make sure that, uh, I just want to make sure that, you know, you know, no one says anything bad on my stream.
Just, you know, just the little things.
Yeah, so there is a, apparently there is the 1% because some people actually kept the stuff in the inventory.
Uh, I believe my coordinates is a 0-0, I think.
I think this is 0-0, right?
Uh, the old land claims are still around.
Wait, really?
Wait, did we not wipe the claims?
We should have wiped the claims.
Yeah, there's nobody here.
Yeah, see?
There's no way the old land claims are still around.
There's no way.
Because, uh, Um, because, like, these claims are all new.
Alright, the rich get richer.
Alright, I'm gonna create my- my area next to the- next to here.
I wonder if this is the same- I think this is.
Okay, if I see the ocean that way, then it's the same land.
It's the same- what's it called?
Uh, the same seed.
So, they wiped everything.
Uh, but you were on the- oh my god, it's the same fucking seed.
Okay, okay.
I swear- I swear- I swear to god.
I know you guys know we're the end.
Okay, we're gonna do the ender dragon together.
This time.
Okay, everyone?
We're gonna- we're gonna do the ender dragon together.
Guys, okay, this- I don't remember where I used to live.
I actually don't.
I remember I was on a hill.
Uh, um, okay, we'll do it soon.
We'll do it soon.
I just need to claim my lands.
Guys, you remember where I lived?
I remember I lived on a hill, so I can- I'd be like, Simba, everywhere the sun touches belongs to you.
Uh, uh...
I- I- I- I need- I think it was here, right?
I'd be like, Simba.
If I don't remember, it's been so long.
It's been so fucking long.
It's like, here, right?
Yeah, this was it, right?
Yeah, this was it.
This was it.
I remember- this was it.
This was my land.
Oh my god, give me.
Give me your gear right now.
Give me a- I- I see what you have.
I need- give me your fireworks right now.
And your gear.
This is a holdup.
This is- I'll kick you- I'll un-whitelist you.
No, I want your fireworks and your cape.
Now.
All right, take that cape off the back- off your back.
I'm gonna get out of here.
I'm tired.
That's right.
Don't make me use force.
Don't...
Give me your lecture right now!
Don't make me use force on you!
The land isn't claimed so I can PvP.
That's right!
Alright, nice.
Okay, now I'll claim my land.
Now don't give in.
Alright, this is new Joki Town.
I'm trying to remember how to do this.
I'm trying to claim my land.
A behind-away robbery.
Everything the sun touches is yours.
It's so cute.
Alright.
I think I'm doing it correctly, right?
I think?
Did I claim it?
I don't remember.
Ow!
Okay, wait.
Okay.
Alright, I claimed it.
Lands claim.
Did I do it?
Oh, nice.
I successfully claimed this chunk of land.
Okay.
And then... Um... What do I do?
What do I... What do I do after that?
New claims... Will belong... Okay.
Okay, I got it.
Wait.
Okay, wait.
How do I...
Time to get boxed in.
Not if I claim more!
If I start claiming more land, you can't box me in.
Okay.
Alright.
Slash...
Claim...
Lands...
Auto...
Fill...
Oh, okay.
Slash...
Claim...
Radius...
Did I do it?
Which one's mine?
Claim...
Okay.
Is this all mine?
I think this is all mine.
Oh my god.
I'm trying to remember, guys.
Is this still my lands?
I...
Oh my god.
Everybody's already claiming so much.
I...
Okay.
Claim...
Guys, we are basically stress testing everything out right now.
So...
Um...
Oh!
Who logged out before in their land?
Can't claim?
Alright Moz, you heard that?
Fix that.
Fix that, guys.
Guys, I need to look at the instructions again.
It's been... it's been so long since I've played the land.
Let me... let me... what are the commands?
Okay.
Um... in-game commands.
Oh, land.
Rename.
Okay.
Land set spot.
Okay, this is my spot.
Okay.
Land set spot.
What?
Um... um... wait.
Land rename Doki Land.
Okay, nice.
For... what?
Wait.
Why does it say someone else owns this land?
What?
Why does it...
Okay, so what's that?
Wait.
I renamed your land?
Where is... wait.
TP... spot.
This is my spot.
TP spot.
Oh my god.
Where am I?
Wait.
My land.
What?
Come on.
Wait.
Slash map.
Wait, but I'm trusted.
I'm trusted in this land.
Is this not mine?
What?
This is...
This is... your land is our land.
This is not my land?
Guys, this is... these instructions... okay.
Land... set... spawn.
But like...
What?
Am I alive?
I heard something explode.
Oh, I'm alive.
Okay.
It was my land.
What happened to my land?
What?
Wait.
TP...
Oh my god.
What happened?
What?
Okay, guys.
Guys, we might... can we reset... okay, guys, we're gonna try... I'm gonna ask them to reset all land claims.
Can we...
Can we reset all land claims?
People can't claim lands.
And I want my land... and I want my land back.
Okay, we're looking into that right now.
We're resetting every... Don't worry, all land claims will be... And we'll full wipe... Wait, no, okay.
Full wipe everything but my inventory.
Alright, guys, give me your shit.
Give me... And full wipe everyone's inventory but mine.
Is it actually possible?
Alright, guys.
We're gonna full wipe everybody's inventory but my inventory.
So if you guys want me to receive anything right now, chat it over.
Don't worry, I'll give it back, guys.
I'll give... I'll give everything...
Okay, the seed will be the same... Don't worry, I'll give everything back.
I'll be your bank.
Alright, if anyone wants to do a safe tip of deposit on me, you can right now.
I'll go back through the city hall.
Where is the city hall?
Ooh, it's the wild.
Guys, oh, there it is.
Alright, I'll have... Don't worry, guys.
Guys, alright, everybody.
Go to the city hall.
I'll be your safety deposit bank.
And I'll return everything.
Don't worry.
Don't worry, guys.
Alright, don't worry.
Give me your armor.
If anyone wants me to safeguard their armor, their netherite armor and everything, I can safeguard it all.
I'll be your safety deposit box, guys.
Do not worry.
If anyone has anything important that they want me to hold on to, I'm here for you, guys.
Don't worry, guys.
Don't worry.
The bank is here.
I'll safeguard it for all of you.
So, I asked them to wipe everybody's inventory, guys.
So, except for mine.
Except for mine.
Alright, but we're keeping the old seed.
But we're keeping the old seed.
We just need to...
Yeah, alright, guys.
Yeah?
Oh, don't worry.
I got you, guys.
I got you.
Alright.
If you guys... Okay, wait.
Let me make a chest.
A bank chest.
Okay, actually... Someone make the safety deposit box, guys.
Alright.
Let's go here.
You make the safety deposit...
Make the safety deposit box.
Wait.
And here.
Alright.
And then...
Everyone that wants to deposit their items.
Um...
Wait.
Can we not put it?
Or maybe here?
Oh, my God.
The ender dragon has died yet again.
Alright.
I need any... Someone to make...
A safety deposit box.
So, I can make sure...
I can hold all your stuff together.
We are going to reset...
The land claims.
And all your inventory.
So that there's no more 1% anymore.
Um...
So, there won't be a 1%.
And everybody has to start from the beginning.
Alright.
Where's the box?
Who has the box?
Guys, I don't have enough...
To make a box.
Oh, wait.
The shulker box.
Alright, guys.
Alright, everybody.
Okay.
It's just all fish.
But that's okay.
That's okay.
It's just fish.
Let me get rid of that.
Oh, my God.
Let me get rid of all the fish.
Okay.
The shulker box is our little safety deposit box.
Guys.
Let me get rid of all...
Oh, my God.
Let me get rid of the fish.
Alright.
And then, deposit your items!
Deposit your items, everybody!
Weeee!
Alright.
Put it in this box, guys!
Put all your-wait, can you guys not access this?
Can't you guys not access... whoops, whoops.
It's just, it's unclear.
We can't access the box.
Okay, we'll try it here.
All right, we'll try it again.
All right, don't worry.
Okay, okay, how about this?
We do sing... I believe in us.
All right, I have an idea.
While the staff is figuring out how to...
how to unclaim all lands, I have an idea, everybody.
Like I said, we're all doing this live.
Okay, this will be...
All right, you line up one by one.
Line up in a single file and offer me the thing you want to deposit.
In a single file!
Single file!
No, you can't be in front of me.
You have to be...
You can't be behind me.
You have to be in front of me.
Go!
Anyone that's behind me does not get to have a safety deposit box.
Go behind!
Go... I mean, go in front of me!
Go in front of me!
Go in...
Okay.
In front!
Anyone behind me?
Okay, this didn't work, guys.
Okay!
In front of me!
Alright!
Stop!
Okay!
Alright!
What do you have to offer?
Okay, you don't have to move up every time!
You don't have to move up!
Just... Alright!
What do you have to offer in the safety deposit box?
What do you have to offer?
Let me grab... kick away my fish first.
Get the junk out of the way.
Get the junk out.
Alright!
What's your offering?
I'll make sure to keep it all safe.
Very safe.
Don't worry.
I'll keep this very safe.
Do not worry.
I'll keep this all very, very safe for you.
You know how I can make it extra safe?
If it's on my body.
Don't...
Don't worry!
I'll... make sure you'll have all your items back.
Whoa!
Oh my god!
I got an achievement, guys.
Don't worry!
This is a very trusted safety deposit box.
This is... This is...
It will be... Alright!
That's enough safety!
I have... I have enough...
Enough safety deposits.
I... I have... I have... That's enough safety!
That's... Seriously...
Alright, guys.
I have... That's enough safety deposit box.
The bank has closed.
Sorry.
You gotta come back tomorrow.
Oh, sorry.
Tomorrow's Sunday.
You gotta come back on Monday.
You have to come back on Monday to access the bank.
It's closing hours.
We gotta go home.
Alright, let me see what the mod say.
We're on it?
Okay, how long?
Estimated time.
Alright, SM... Oh, you guys want... Let's see the old lands.
Alright, I want to tour the old relic while they're...
While they're fixing unclaiming all lands, we're gonna check out the old lands.
I think it's... How is it?
I have to look through the command list.
Old SMP, okay.
Alright.
The old lands.
So, this is the old... The old lands right here.
Wait.
Is it the old lands?
Oh, yeah, it is!
You can see all the...
Old structures and everything.
Look at that.
Hello, everyone.
You see everything they made back then?
Relics of the past.
And everything.
Look, there's the...
The fuck is that?
Oh, my God.
This is so cool.
This is Doki Land.
Yeah.
Our seaport.
The old seaport in Doki Land.
That's pretty cool back then.
Oh, my God.
Look at all these builds.
I never got a chance to see all the amazing builds you guys did in here.
So, we're giving a tour while...
Looking through it all.
And there's the...
The Oshi mark right here.
We're at number one.
She was number...
Oh, there's a drag horn on top of it, too!
Can we set daytime?
I don't think I'm allowed to.
I don't think I'm allowed to set the daytime.
And then...
There's that.
Oh, there's an airship.
That's so cool.
There is an airship.
And everything, too.
Oh, my God.
There's...
There's Hatsune Miku.
There's Hatsune...
He has no power here.
Is the time set?
Time set.
I don't think I'm allowed to.
Day...
Set...
No.
Time...
Add...
I don't know.
Three...
Days.
Seconds.
Three seconds.
Oh, shit.
I did it.
Oh, wait.
Oh, I...
Silent Croaky did it.
I thought I did it.
I was like, Whoa!
But it was Silent Croaky.
It was...
Oh, there's the...
Oh, my God.
There's Squidward's house.
Wait, someone made Squidward's house?
That's so cool.
That's...
Okay.
Wait, is that the prison?
Wait, I think this was a...
I was like, Whoa!
I did it!
And then I was like, Oh...
Oh...
I didn't do it.
No, no, no, no.
Wipe everybody's inventories.
Wipe everyone's...
Inventory.
But mine.
Mine is the most important.
Wait, let me make sure.
I'm gonna message that to the mods right now.
To make sure they get that...
No, I am a...
I am the safety deposit.
That's right.
Don't keep throwing the horse.
For an evil ink.
Okay, I'm not evil.
I'm just... it's just really hard to be a ruler, okay?
You gotta make sacrifices.
Okay, guys.
You gotta... you gotta make sacrifices for what's right.
For the land.
Oh, hey, Kroki.
Ah!
Okay.
What else is there?
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh, there's bunnies.
I thought it says Benny.
Oh my god, there's a Benny's here?
There's a...
Whoa, oh my god!
That's so cool!
There's like a creed!
This is actually the port!
Toki Land port!
Oh my god!
There's a fucking...
There's just a giant ship!
There's a Denny's here?
Oh my god, this place has everything!
There's a Denny's here at Toki Land!
There's a...
Whoa!
Alright, don't worry.
We can rebuild and make it even better.
See, what else is there?
I'm like flying so...
Alright, wait, actually let me...
Wipe everyone's...
Inventory...
But...
Mine!
I'm about to message that.
Don't worry.
Don't they know now?
Oh, and then there's the...
All the...
Chips...
At Doki Land.
The seaport.
We're...
Oh my god.
Our trading station...
Our trading ports.
We are very...
We are very rich in resources and trade.
White Toki...
No!
No, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no.
The Dragoons has depended on me.
On being a safety deposit box.
Uh...
Hahaha....
There's uh...
Doki drinks.
Oh, that's cool.
Alright.
Oh, there's a lighthouse, too!
Oh, that's so cool.
There's a lighthouse...
And everything.
What else in there?
Oh, there's apparently a shopping district?
No, no, no.
I...
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Doki bank will survive.
Will survive the great wife.
Server is lagging.
Oh, maybe they're trying to wipe everything right now.
Is this a shopping district?
Okay, no, that's not.
This is the Toki Salute.
This is an actual town.
All right.
No, no, no, no, no.
We are... we have been around for generations.
Your families have always depended on us.
Yeah, there's so many cool things.
You need to teleport to them.
How do I accept?
I don't... Oh, there it is.
What is this?
Where is this area?
Is this a shopping mall?
Oh my god.
Wait.
Was this a shopping mall?
What is this?
Oh my god, wait.
What the fuck is this?
What was this?
It's a capitol building?
Oh my god, is this my white house?
Is this...
Oh my god.
Is this my white house?
It's an island.
We're in the middle of nowhere.
Oh my god, guys.
It's my white house.
Right there.
The Toki house.
Yeah.
I was gonna say, make it yellow.
The yellow house.
Alright.
What else is there?
Alright, if you guys wanted me to see your builds in the...
Um, the old town.
Just...
Let me TP to you.
Oh my god, I'm loading everything in right now.
Alright.
I'll TP to you.
Alright, what is this?
Pathway to the shopping district.
Oh.
Read before entering.
No.
I refuse.
Wait, what?
How do we enter the shopping district?
How...
Oh, the voice chat mod is not working?
Don't worry.
We'll fix that.
We'll fix that in post.
The reason why...
Oh wait.
We had a decision to either...
Um...
Okay, we had the decision to either, uh...
Do...
Um...
Let members in early and then figure it out before the stream starts.
Or...
Wait, what does this say?
Now entering the hallway to Electric Boogaloo.
No, no.
This is actual throwback.
Oh my god.
This is fucking throwback.
The things...
The sins I've committed.
Uh...
But then I was like...
I feel like it would have been more fun.
I don't know.
I feel like it'd be more fun to...
Oh my god.
There's like a sea view too.
Uh...
If you wanna shop, you gotta go through the doors.
Oh my...
I'm still going.
Uh...
Oh wait, it's pink now.
At least.
Oh, it's pink.
Okay, and then it's back to yellow.
Wait, what was I talking about?
Oh yeah.
We had to do it live.
I decided to do it live.
Because I felt like it's a more fun experience for everybody.
If we all like...
Experience it together.
Rather than having the members like, you know...
Getting in there first and start claiming stuff.
I felt like it'd be better if we were all there together at the same time.
That would drive someone insane.
This is...
This is actually impressive.
I...
That was my very first build.
This is...
My...
I did...
I did like...
If you guys ever see my very...
My...
Very first Minecraft stream.
This is basically what I did.
As my very first Minecraft stream.
But like...
They took that concept.
And...
Uh...
They...
They took that concept.
And like...
Did me like...
Times a hundred.
Uh...
Why though?
Because...
I thought it was funny.
I thought it was really funny.
And I was right.
I...
Yeah, they expanded it a little bit.
They...
It...
It was funny.
It was worth it.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh my god!
Where does it end?
Where does it actually end?
Oh my god!
Is this where it ends?
It's still going...
I...
I can't find the ending.
I can't...
Oh my god!
It...
It actually doesn't end!
I'm so...
Walk...
I'm...
It's still going on!
Holy...
Does it end here?
Oh my god!
Is that the end?
I can't tell.
Wait...
Where did...
Oh my god!
Where did it go?
I just...
Okay!
It's still going...
Guys!
Okay!
I will go back to the world when I find the ending of this.
I...
Does it end?
It should end, right?
Oh my god!
Okay!
Wait!
There is still going on!
It's still...
Oh my god!
I'm still...
But wait!
There's more!
I don't know!
There's...
There's more!
Oh my god!
Guys, I think they expanded my concept just...
Just a bit more than my old one.
They need...
Make sure you can't dig out.
Like...
How...
How far does it go?
I need to see the ending.
I...
I have to see the ending of this.
Like...
Did they just do this every day?
This was their job!
They...
They log in!
They log in and just do this.
9...
This was their 9 to 5...
Every day until the server shut down.
Like...
They were too committed now.
This was their 9 to 5.
I'm...
Oh my god!
There's the ending!
Guys!
It's here!
We made it!
We actually...
We visited again!
Called generally the worst thing I've ever been through...
In Minecraft...
Was funny for...
A bit...
The...
The tunnel...
That's actually crazy!
You...
Oh my god!
How did I miss something?
I went through so much!
Well...
Why...
But I should have asked!
What would I have missed?
I went through this entire tunnel!
Okay, there's the shopping...
Are we...
Are we here?
Are we in the shopping district now?
Is this the...
Mall?
Is this the mall?
Alright...
Proudly shopping district...
Get your ads today!
Shop for...
Oh my god!
It's proudly sponsored!
This was an actual ad!
Right up past the...
Guys...
Guys, are you guys ready to do this...
To rebuild this area?
Skip the ad!
Oh my god!
This was the shopping district!
Alright...
What's this?
Join the shop...
Oh wait, that's an ad!
You gotta pay me for that!
Oh, we can't press...
We can't play it!
No!
No, you don't get that ad!
You gotta pay me if you want ad space!
No, it's not getting wiped!
You can, like...
Revisit the ancient area!
Oh my god!
There's a billboard and everything!
The Doki Mall!
Oh my god!
There's a fast food restaurant here!
That's crazy!
Oh my god!
Should you ignore the full netherite beacon?
That's not important!
That's...
Alright, alright!
We go back to...
Uh...
How was the command again?
Oh, by the way!
All the commands is on that server too!
Uh...
The Doki SMP!
Cause, like...
They've been waiting for me!
Uh...
They've been waiting for me for...
They've been waiting for me!
Alright, I'm back!
Wait...
I'm not back!
I...
Wait, why am I still a ghost?
Wait, why am I...
Why am I...
A ghost?
Oh...
Um...
Uh...
That's awkward!
Wait, no!
This is still the old area!
Wait, how do I...
Oh!
A SMP!
Sorry!
SMP!
There we go!
If you click...
SMP!
Alright!
Wipe their inventory!
I still see people...
Did everybody's inventory got wiped?
No, cause I still see diamond pickaxes!
Did everyone's...
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha ha!
Oh!
Excluding one person takes a bit!
Ha ha ha ha!
Oh, they're slowly wiping everybody's...
Good!
Slowly wipe everybody's inventory!
Uh...
Ha ha ha!
No, it's okay, there!
They're doing it one by one!
They're do...
Ha ha ha ha!
That's so fucked up!
Wait, where's my feather?
What is...
That's so fucked up!
I like it!
Alright, selection tool...
Wait, I lost my feather...
Oh, there it is!
Nice!
Alright!
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Yes!
Ha ha ha!
Alright!
I'll get...
I'll get my land back...
Just to inflict more pain...
Ha ha ha ha!
Oh, only I can claim land!
Yes!
Ha ha ha!
I claim my land first!
I need to get my...
My hill!
Everything the sun touches is mine!
Wait, okay, after I...
Okay, but we're...
Give me the teleport coordination of the very important thing!
I'm not doing that!
I'm not doing that again!
I'm not going through the hallway again to find it!
Ha ha ha!
Alright!
Okay!
Are you serious?
Who claimed this land?
Who claimed it already?!
Wipe this area!
Ha ha ha!
Kroki!
Remove this man's claim!
Right now!
Ha ha ha ha!
Remove this man's claim!
Just his!
Just his though!
Just...
Ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha!
I'm waiting.
I'm waiting to tell you.
Okay, I'll directly message him too.
Remove this man's claim right now.
Alright.
Nice.
Okay.
Has it been removed?
Yes!
Wait.
Has it?
Where am I?
Where am I anyway?
Wait, where am I?
I don't know where I am.
Shoot.
Wait, I don't think this is it.
Wait.
Where did I go?
I got TP'd somewhere.
No, this is not the hill.
I know my hills.
This is not my hill.
What happened to my hill?
I got yeeted.
Wait.
Okay.
Set the... Oh my god.
Where am I?
I actually got yeeted somewhere.
I don't know where I got yeeted to.
Okay, wait.
TP spawn.
Wait.
T... T... P...
Uh...
Lobby.
Wait, how do I... Okay.
I need to tab out.
Okay.
Lobby.
It's slash lobby.
Alright.
There you go.
Okay.
I will find my hill.
But my... my...
My staff is listening.
My army is listening.
Unclaim that man's land right now.
They're gonna unclaim that man's land.
Don't worry.
I'm going back.
I'm going back to my hill.
Unclaim his land right now.
Un...
Alright.
Alright, that's his name, shoot him!
Shoot him!
That's his name, that's his name, shoot this guy!
Oh shit, someone didn't sleep.
What claiming add-on are you using?
I don't know, it's a plug-in that was programmed.
Okay.
I can't claim land because I am a member of Journey.
What's wrong with that?
I claim.
Okay.
Slash claim.
Oh my god.
I claim... Shoot him!
Transfer your land to me right now.
Mod, make him transfer his land to me.
Okay, wait.
Forrest, transfer... Forrest... Transfer his land to me.
Forrest, transfer his... This is the perfect song to play, too, while we're doing this.
This is the dookie games right now.
I'm waiting.
I'm waiting until... Until the mod... Forrest, transfer this land back to me.
Take his land!
That's what you get for taking dookie land.
Okay, I gotta get rid of the... What's the setting for that?
The... That shows the... All the stuff on my far right?
I don't remember.
Is this accessibility?
Which one was that?
I'll get rid of that.
Is it subtitles?
Oh, there you go.
Subtitles.
There you go.
Okay, he's trying.
Okay, I believe.
He's trying right now.
He's trying.
Okay.
All right.
Oh, wait.
It's the wilderness now.
Wait!
Wait, it's the wilderness!
Yes!
No!
Drop!
Slash claim.
Did I do it?
I claimed one ch... I only got one chunk?!
Oh my god, I only got one chunk.
I only got one chunk.
Slash claim.
Where's my land?
I can't tell.
Who owns this land?
Who owns...
Okay, yeah, make it...
Make it land.
Make the...
Where's my land?
Okay, make the...
Make it day.
Make it day, guys.
Oh, don't...
Oh, I did it!
I claimed my land!
Alright, take this guy's land, too.
Wait, did I do it?
Did I do it?
This is mine, right?
How far...
How far is my land?
How far is it?
I don't know how far it is.
Okay, just claim more.
Okay.
Slash...
Claim.
That...
Selection is not...
Please make selection by land selection.
Okay.
Land...
Selection.
Oh.
Alright.
Okay.
My land.
The Ender Dragon's dead again.
Land...
Claim.
Wait.
Claim...
Land.
Okay.
I don't remember my commands.
I'm like, all over the place.
Oh, it's claim.
It's claim.
Okay.
Claim.
Should I have scissors?
You can claim this by executing...
Oh.
Land...
Selection.
Oh.
Land...
Selection.
Oh, shit.
I...
I'm so confused.
Guys, it's been so long.
Okay.
Slash claim.
Wait.
What?
This is my land.
Who...
Who owns this area?
Oh, wait.
I got everything.
Okay.
But it's so tiny.
I gotta claim more.
Slash...
Claim.
Wait.
What?
Who claimed this?
Take this...
Transfer this land to my land.
Guys.
Mod.
Take this land back.
Force transfer this guy's land to me.
Right now, Mod.
I'll give the name.
AJ.
Okay.
Hey.
Force...
Transfer...
This land over right now.
Force...
Transfer...
Their land.
Their land to me.
Right.
Wait.
I demand this land to be my land.
My Kamiyoshi is stealing land.
The British are coming.
Oh, they can't because... Oh, sorry.
Too soon?
They actually can't, though.
That's a bit too soon.
This land is my land.
Alright.
What's his name?
AJ.
I have the unclaimed land for you in Fixed Inventory.
Not the laws.
The keys are going to tear.
It's getting so bad.
The ended dragon hat and an aneurysm will freaking die.
Okay, don't worry.
I have your name now.
Every land you claim will belong to me.
How dare you take my mountain, is his name.
I wrote your name down.
It's too late.
Your entire land will be mine.
That's right.
I have an eviction law.
Wait.
What happened?
Okay.
Oh my god, it's gone.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Damn.
Wait, what?
But it said wilderness.
What is the wilderness?
Okay.
I'm gonna claim as much as I can.
That's fucking right.
Claim.
Alright.
I'll figure this out.
Claim.
Alright.
Bro, who stole my land?
Claim.
Alright.
Oh, I claimed seven.
Oh!
I claimed seven!
Okay.
I got seven land.
I think...
What else is mine?
Is this also mine?
Okay.
Wait, wait.
I figured it out.
Guys, I figured it out.
Claim.
I claimed three more chunks!
Don't get land!
Did I do it?
That's right!
I got my land back!
You whore!
I got it back!
That's fucking right!
You can't claim shit!
Claiming more.
The fuck?
Who fucking sent the wizard?
That's right!
It's all mine now!
That's fucking right!
It unclaimed your land!
That's right!
Where is he?
I need a...
Now kick him out of my...
No, I'm serious.
Joking.
I'm joking.
Don't kick him out of my... Yeah, that's looking right!
That's right!
Wait, this is my area.
Why can't I kill him in my own land?
I should be allowed to kill someone on my own land.
That's right.
I told you your land will be my land.
I told you.
I... Shit.
Where is he?
Oh, there he is.
Who the fuck summoned him?
This is my... Why is there... Guys, kill him!
Oh, yeah.
You guys don't have inventory anymore.
Only I do.
Okay, wait.
Wow.
Guys, guys, figure out the wither.
I'm gonna... I'm gonna rename my land.
What's the command?
Give me a sec.
How do I rename land again, guys?
What's the command?
Save.
What?
That's someone else.
I believe in you guys.
Oh, shit.
Wait.
He's hitting me.
That's not supposed to happen.
Wait.
Who the fuck still had the wither shit on them?
It's okay.
I'll fly over here.
I don't know.
It's alright.
There's Germany.
Alright.
Let me read this real quick, guys.
Let me read the instructions real quick.
Alright.
Okay.
Set home.
We gotta set home for that.
And then...
Lands rename.
Okay.
We gotta go back.
I think that's where...
Yeah.
We gotta go back.
Alright.
We figured this out.
We're slowly learning how to play again.
Okay.
He's, like, almost dead.
Guys.
I swear to God.
If I come back and my hill is gone.
Wait.
Croaky, can you, like, kill him for us real quick?
Can you...
Say home.
Yeah.
Alright.
And then...
Uh...
Okay.
Save us prokey.
Lands rename.
Okay.
Alright.
And then...
Joke me lands.
Wait, who took TokiLand?
Mon, unnamed that man's land right now.
Who copyright patented TokiLand before I could?
Mon, un-copyright claims, un-trademarked right now.
Yoink.
Also, make it daytime.
Make it daytime.
Wait, why can you build on my land?
This is... Oh wait, that's just the one area that's not mine.
Until now.
That's right.
It's my land now.
I own this now.
That's right.
I own it now.
I can't do anything.
Jump!
That's okay, right?
It's my land now.
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, un-claim... un-trademark... un-trademark that name.
Am I watching Lord of the Flies?
Alright, this is all mine.
Everything the sun touches is mine now.
Alright.
Claim.
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
Okay, delete.
Alright.
Oh my god!
I can un-claim other people's lands!
And then...
They just...
I can un-claim other people's lands, and then claim them as my own!
Oh my god!
Goodbye, Germany!
Good- I can't stop!
I can't- I can't- I can't- Where's Germany?
Which has too much power.
Oh, jeez.
Wait, this is a lot for my land.
What the fuck?
How did I got land all the way here?
Wait, wait, what the fuck?
How did I have land here?
She's becoming a tyrant.
Wait, why do I have land all the way here?
Holy shit.
Oh, shit!
Go back, go back!
I gotta go back.
I claimed too much.
I claimed too... Okay, this is a bit too much land now.
I stole this crafting.
Guys, I have too much land now.
Okay, let's unclaim a bit some stuff.
This is too much land.
Unclaim.
Okay.
Oh.
It's fine.
I have my land.
I'm back on my land.
You can't do shit.
That's right.
You can't do shit on my land.
That's fucking right.
That's fucking... Why do I have land?
Guys, you see that?
I have land right there.
This random patch of land.
Right there.
I have to clean this man's crafting table.
I was like, wait a minute.
When do I have... Okay, let's get rid of this.
Unclaim.
Okay.
Yeah, I was like, this is like...
I don't need that.
Because you tried to claim Germany.
I was like, I don't need that land.
Guys, you're like flies to me.
You do nothing.
Yeah, it's like...
It's like silly.
You actually do nothing to me.
All right, here we go.
This is what Green does.
Look at that.
All right.
Okay, wait.
Um...
Remove...
Whoever...
Is...
Doki-land.
Yeah.
Un...
I want that name back.
I'm copyright striking them.
I'm gonna copyright strike them.
Yeah, land name.
I'm copyright striking them.
That's right.
I copyright claim my name back.
That's fucking right.
It's mine.
Also, I hope the sound has been okay so far.
Let me check in the tab.
That's right.
We're fighting.
Also, also, tell me who did it.
Tell me who did it.
I'm sending a DMCA.
Donkey land is my land.
That's right.
I'm gonna send a DMCA.
She's so struck with power.
That's fucking right.
I'll find you.
I'll fucking find you.
Donkey cannot be so eerie, actually.
Also, sound guy.
How's the sound so far?
I want to make sure everybody can hear my plans.
Why even bother giving people the option to claim mad land when you're just gonna claim...
No, I am... No, no, no.
That's not true.
I'm giving them the privilege to build around my land.
I'm giving them the privilege to build on my land.
Guys, that's not true.
I am a just ruler.
I... I... I...
They get the privilege to be here.
I... That's how it works.
I'm leasing it out.
I'm leasing it out to everyone.
That's right.
The land tastes better when they used to belong to someone.
Wait, who owns this area?
Unclaimed!
Did they actually build anything yet?
Oh, they did!
What if- what if I just unclaimed?
I won't.
No, not yet.
Not- not yet.
That'd be so messed up.
Yoink, my land now.
His home, my home.
I'll let him live here for a little bit.
Now that you spent several thousand dollars on a Minecraft server, you deserve a little power trip as exactly- exactly has spent money on this.
I deserve- I deserve this.
I'll let them develop the land a little bit before the government comes back to claim it.
You know, the right way, you know?
The- the- The usual way.
You know?
Too real!
Dude, I'm just waiting for- I'm just waiting until I can claim Doki land back.
My best destiny, their ass.
No, it's just the usual.
Alright, I cannot get it.
Oh yeah, I forgot.
Okay.
Someone give me a box real quick.
Someone- Someone make me a- Someone give me a box, just a regular chest.
I need a chest now.
I need a chest- I forgot.
My taxes.
We gotta- We gotta set forth the Doki tax.
Give me a box.
Give me a chest right now.
We need Doki tax.
We need to bring it back.
If you are living on my land, you need to pay your taxes.
Everything the sun touches is my land.
All right.
I gotta remember, like, where can I put this?
Wait, can they put- They can't open- Oh, they can't open my chest on my land.
So, I need to find the wilderness area.
I need, like- One patch of wilderness for my taxes.
Okay, here.
All right.
This is where- Alright, put a sign.
Someone put a sign.
Someone put a- Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey- Hey, hey.
Hey, hey, hey.
Alright.
I need a sign.
Make a sign.
Put it, Doki taxes.
I'm delegating.
You know how I used to like, do it myself?
Now delegate my taxes.
Go...
Make a sign.
Tell everyone that's where you put your taxes.
Right there.
Make it daytime too!
Wait, can I?
Do I have to...
How do I do time again?
I don't remember.
Time.
And...
Did I do it?
Oh, I did it.
I did that this time.
That's right.
It'll never be nighttime in Doki land.
Alright.
Let's see.
What was I plan... Oh, yeah.
Okay.
Land name Doki land.
Did it work?
Wait.
What was it?
Land rename.
Okay.
Land...
Rename Doki land.
When do I get Doki land back?
I will find you.
You know, I'm gonna find you right now.
I'm gonna find you right...
I will find...
Wait, what?
That...
When did I claim this area?
Wait, wilderness.
Is this mine?
Is this accidentally my land?
Wait.
Wait, what...
Okay.
Okay, we got unclaimed this.
I don't know how I have this land, too.
Like, I...
Unclaimed.
Alright.
Okay, this is the wilderness now.
I was like, whose land is that?
Okay, as long as this land is still mine, it's fine.
Okay.
I transferred all the land to me.
I gotta make sure that this is still my land though.
Yeah, alright, this is mine.
From when you decide... Guys, I know I didn't invade Germany that one time.
Alright, Doki Cult.
I will find the one that took Doki Land.
I will find it.
I will find you.
Apparently the research world might be bugged.
Alright.
Wilderness.
Oh, someone claimed here.
Okay, that's not you.
I need to find the port.
Uh...
I think it's bugged.
I can't... Alright, if there...
If you guys, by the way...
If there's any bugs or...
Any issues that you find, just report it on the Discord server.
And they'll like, record...
They'll like, note it down and fix it.
Ba-dum, ba-dum.
Alright.
Oh my god.
I can't seem to find it.
Okay.
Spawn.
Lobby.
Oh yeah!
By the way, we have a new feature.
Wait, let's see.
Where is it called?
Spawn...
Uh...
Is it faction?
Ha ha ha ha.
Slash...
Teleport...
Lobby.
What is it?
Oh!
Let's go to...
Slash...
Spawn...
Oh, warp list.
Okay.
Slash...
Spawn...
Spawn.
Wait, no, this is not the faction area.
Where's the faction area?
Slash warplist.
Okay.
There you go.
Okay, so you can see here, if you do warplist, and then gladiator...
How do I do that?
And then we click gladiator arena.
And then this is the PvP area.
So all you have to do is...
Pick your faction.
And then you fight.
Alright, don't worry.
Set it to daytime!
I demand for it to be day.
Jokey bird has...
Nice, alright.
There we go.
Trying to figure out how...
Okay.
So there's a gladiator arena.
Now.
And...
Remember how to like...
Set this up.
Alright.
It's right here.
Match.
So you click that.
And we fight.
Who's on the other side?
That's right.
We're gonna...
I think I want to readjust this gladiator area though.
Come on.
Oh, it closes in 12 seconds.
You can team up with other dragoons too.
And everything.
My five.
Oh, shit.
Hello.
Begins...
Who's on the other side?
I don't think there's any...
Who is on the other side?
Come forth dragoons.
Defend your queen.
That's right.
It's PvP time.
Go.
It's 3v3.
You guys can do it.
I believe.
That's right.
Don't worry.
I got you.
Wait, but who's got me?
Who's got me?
Don't worry.
They'll never expect a back.
Wait, am I red or blue?
I...
Wait, what?
Oh, I'm blue.
Someone help me!
I just forgot my color.
Oh my God.
It's just us two.
Oh, no!
You were supposed to defend me.
You were...
No elf.
Just as the prophecy for Tooth.
Nothing happened.
I erased that history.
What do you mean?
I just logged in, guys.
Nothing happened.
No.
What do you mean?
Nothing happened.
I just got here.
Alright, back to my land.
Oh, wait.
TP home.
Wait.
How do I TP back?
Home.
Doki Birdo.
Oh, it's at...
Home.
Doki Birdo.
Wait, what?
Home.
I will find it.
Oh, it's my land!
Wait, no.
What?
Why does it say Doki Land?
But, like, it's not Doki Land.
Oh, wait.
It was mine all alone?
Home.
Oh my God.
It was mine all alone.
Wait, what?
It was mine all alone?
What?
This was my land?
Oh my God.
This was my land.
I was like, guys, that was not a safe TP.
What
happened to me?
I was like, how could it not be safe?
It's my land.
I was so confused.
I was like, guys, that was not a safe TP.
That was absolutely not a safe TP.
That, that...
What just said?
It said non-safe TP.
I was like, that's not...
That's not true.
How could it not be safe?
How could...
How could that... How could that not be said?
That's not possible.
That's not... That's not possible.
That was... What a wild TV.
I... I was very confused.
I was very confused.
Alright.
Okay.
Slash spa.
What?
Slash... Home.
Okay.
Teleport.
There we go.
Why does it say Stokey Brito?
Come on!
Fix this!
Just fix this!
Come on!
Fix this right now.
Some teleport points.
Some like... Home person from the old...
It's a lottery.
Why are you the way you are?
What's that supposed to mean?
Doki Land.
Okay.
Nice.
This is a new home called Doki Land.
Okay.
Spawn.
What?
Okay.
Slash... Home.
Slash...
Home.
Doki Land.
Teleport.
Okay.
Guys, we need to fix this.
Why are you all here sitting in my land?
Why?
Slash...
Lands...
Spawn.
Oh my god.
Okay.
We're squatted.
Get out!
This is my...
Squat...
Leave!
Squatters!
You can't fight them here.
This area belongs...
I am Doki Bird!
Let me kill Doki Bird!
I...
I am Doki Bird!
We have to go...
Hold D...
It won't let me kill!
They're like...
Oh, sorry.
But like...
Oh...
It's gonna...
You can't attack on the land.
This belongs to...
I...
Not a...
But doctor...
I am Doki Bird!
How do they know?
I have to go to the old SMP apparently.
Okay.
Set...
Time...
Wait.
Set...
Zero...
There we go.
So I can see this.
Join the squad.
Squatters Union.
How dare you take my home?
Oh.
By the way.
There's lag because they're increasing ram loads on the main SMP right now.
They're increasing the...
Ram load.
That's like...
Why did you think I went to the old SMP?
I didn't warn you.
That's right.
You squatters...
I...
That's right.
I didn't...
Why did you think I TP'd to the old SMP?
That's fucking right.
That's what you squatters deserve.
That's evil.
That's right.
I didn't inform you guys what was happening.
Oh my god.
There's like a whole fucking village here.
Holy shit.
That's so cool.
You monster.
That's right.
Be trapped in the fucking void.
No rights for squatters.
You get sent to the void.
You're not allowed to squat on Doki land.
Oh, boy crap.
I avoided the void.
Stupid.
Why did you think I fucking TP'd out of here?
The resource zone is so that you guys can grab resources without having to...
Without having to...
What's the word?
Destroy everything.
Oh, wait.
Oh, no.
It's the old SMP turn.
I can't move.
So you don't have to deforest everything as well as the...
Um...
You know, mow down the hills and everything.
What's that word again?
You know?
When they have to like...
Um...
Level the hills and stuff for resources.
The flattening.
Yeah, you don't have to flatten shit.
Oh, wait.
TP...
Scar...
Wait.
Do a TP request to me.
Because I'm...
Do a TP request.
Yeah, we don't have to terraform the actual land.
Okay, that's not...
Okay, I'll...
I'll check it out.
Is it here?
No.
Yeah.
What is this?
Praise to these...
What once was lost shall return.
Black nights forever.
Aww.
Who picked this color?
I was like...
Oh, that's sweet.
And then...
Who picked this color?
Ooh.
That's cool.
Oh, it's scroll wheel.
Oh, I was scroll wheeling.
Oh my god.
That's so cool.
I was like wondering why I was so slow.
Come on.
Meow meow meow meow.
Okay.
We have double the ramp capacity.
Alright.
Nice.
Now we can go back.
Am I allowed to go back now?
Also, I'm gonna grab Tissue real quick.
I need to blow my nose.
I'll be right back.
Okay.
Also, the resource world is fixed.
Alright.
Meow meow meow.
What is it?
Dookie SMP?
There you go.
I should be back.
Oh.
I forgot how to do it again.
I think it was...
What is it?
Just SMP.
Okay.
Slash SMP.
Alright.
Nice.
I'm back.
Alright.
Slash SMP.
I'm back.
Okay.
We did it.
Alright.
Slash.
Home.
List.
Doki land.
There we go.
Okay.
Is it still called Doki land yet?
Is my land called Doki land again?
I gotta know.
Why can't I fight on my own land?
Get out of here, squatters!
That's it.
What's your name?
I will find your... What's your name?
You squatters.
I can see... I'm going to wait until I see your name, squatters.
Get out!
It won't let me rename!
Rename Doki land.
Oh my... Okay, wait.
Rename Doki land 2.
Okay.
Did that work?
Wait.
Unknown command?
Okay.
They are like... Get out!
Leave!
You have to pay rent!
Okay.
Lands rename.
Lands rename Doki land 2.
Okay.
There we go.
Lands rename Doki land.
Wait.
Lands rename Doki...
Doki.
Okay.
That's fine.
I don't know where my hair is.
Okay.
What's your name?
What are my squatters' names?
What are their names?
Oh my god.
They're all together.
What is...
Kill...
Oscar...
That's right!
You saw what I did to Oscar?
That's right, squatters!
You think I can...
That's right!
What if you don't leave my land in 10 seconds?
I'll start killing you off one by one!
10!
On a count of 10!
You better get off my land, you fucking squatters!
Alan, I see your name!
That's right!
I can kill you all!
Leave my land!
I own this land!
Get out!
Who
owns!
Who owns!
I know who owns my... my... my copyright!
My trademark!
Where is...
Where are you?
You're in the resource world?
Where am I?
And this one on... TP silent!
Ok... there we go.
There we go.
Where are you?
Wait, where the fuck?
Ok... TP... silent... croaky... there you go.
Where is he?
That says Greyland!
That's Greyland!
Kylan!
You took my name!
Oh, I renamed it?
Oh my god.
You know what?
Slash kill.
Grey.
Alright.
Slash TP home.
Slash TP.
Slash lobby.
Like this, I'm walking over.
There we go.
That guy, he was the one that took my name.
Okay.
Slash land rename.
Jokeyland.
How is it still taken?
Kroki!
Find me, find me, tell me who it is that took my other name.
Who the only one?
Time, time, set, zero, zero seconds.
There you go.
It'll never be night time until I figure this out.
It'll never be...
Silent Kroki!
Find me the one who took my other... my name again.
You need to be fast.
Yep, alright.
TP!
Get in!
Okay, get in here!
Thanos, get in here!
Kill all these people on my... Kill all the squatters!
Kill all the... Get over here!
Saturn, kill all the squatters!
That's right!
They are leaving!
Do it!
Alright, imitates, alright.
Give all... Where are you?
TP!
Who has claimed my land?
Silently croaky!
Find who can...
Who claimed my land?
Who took my land so I can copyright strike them?
Okay.
I need me original land.
Alright, let's see.
Slash... No, I lost my parent.
Okay.
Land... Land... Rename.
Doki Land Original.
Doki World.
Okay.
Yeah.
Doki World.
You know how there's Disneyland and Disney World?
There we go.
Doki World.
A fun.
Void on Doki Land immediately locked up.
Doki World.
Oh my god.
Wipe this man's... Alright, where is his land?
I'm unclaiming his land.
Kroaky, tell me where he lives.
I'll unclaim his land.
Log back in or I'll unclaim your land right now, Void on.
Log back in right now.
I know where you live.
I will unclaim your land.
Okay, there we go.
Okay.
Get back here.
My mods... My mods... My mods got me here.
Alright, wait.
I need... Take me up there.
I know where you live.
That's right.
If you don't show up, I am unclaiming your land.
I... No.
I can take your shit, too.
That's... I have the power to take your stuff, too.
Nobody found it.
That's right.
On a count of ten.
If you don't show up right now, I'm unclaiming this land.
I'm unclaiming it for myself, too.
Right after.
Ten.
Nine.
Eight.
Seven.
Six.
Five.
Four.
Three.
Two.
One.
Unclaim.
That's fucking right.
All right.
TP.
Homes list.
All right.
Lan.
Lan's rename Doki Lan.
Are you... Who took it again?
Who... Who took it again?
Who took the Lan again?
Who... Oh my god.
I will log in when everyone is asleep and I will fucking take back my Lan.
I... She's incoming to... Someone is still Tokyo World.
Someday she'll get the name.
All right.
That's it.
I'm filing a trademark on Doki World.
At least I have Doki World.
I... I have... I have Doki World.
Dracula's don't sleep.
Just give me the name.
I won't do anything yet.
Is that... Why is he still killing people?
He's just... He's just killing people since I... I'm on my whole arc.
I'm trying to find the... The one who took Doki Land.
And Thanos is still snapping people.
He's still...
There's only you there.
Hundreds of us.
All right.
Tell me who took the next... Who took... Who took it again?
Kroki.
Tell me who.
I won't do anything yet.
For now.
I won't... I won't do anything for now.
I didn't tell that's true.
I didn't tell him to stop.
I will find out.
I will know.
You can't avoid it.
Squad is right there.
No Doki Land.
I'll make sure of it.
I'll find out.
I want to know... Where's the... Is this the port side?
Is this the... Is this the old Doki Land port?
Right here?
Great Dragoon Massacre.
Here.
I'm not afraid.
Was this... Was this the old... Ye old Belgium.
There's Belgium.
Is that the... Is this the Ye old Doki Land port?
Or is it towards the village?
Which one is this?
Is it back here?
All right.
This is the... Is this... What?
Did that say East Germany?
Oh shit.
There's a beacon.
Is it closer to the lobby?
Or is it?
I can't seem to find...
Because I've lost...
I've lost the...
The old port.
The Ye old Doki Land port.
I'll find out who it is.
We figured it out.
Wait.
I figured it out.
Poems list.
Lands.
Rename...
Doki Land.
You liar!
You liar, Kroki!
You liar,
Kroki!
You liar, Kroki!
I actually thought you got away.
Okay.
Okay, unclaim it right now.
Force unclaim his land right now.
It never ends.
There was...
Kroki was helping.
No, Kroki told me he told me he was back on.
He told me he was back on.
Killed him.
Unclaim the land.
And now we're here.
Now...
When one falls...
Lands.
Okay, I'm waiting.
I'm waiting until he force...
Force the name out.
And then I'm fucking renaming it.
I'm ready.
Okay.
Force...
Unclaim...
Unclaim his land right now.
He is hiding underground.
He
is hiding underground.
That's...
I don't know why.
I don't know why he tried the run.
Wait, that's...
Alright.
Okay.
Keep unclaiming.
I'll be here.
Keep...
Keep unclaiming.
I'll eventually be my name.
My world.
It's a fear.
Doki land belongs to the dragoons.
You are on Doki land!
Alright.
Cactus is...
Where is he?
Where's Cactus?
Who keeps claiming it before I can claim it?
He...
He trapped...
Okay.
We gotta be trapped in my mod.
He actually trapped my mod.
So I had to...
He trapped my mod.
So I had to save him.
Alright.
Other mods!
Help him!
Help Sonic Kroki!
My other mods!
Help him!
We'll kill the rest later.
I need you all to...
I need you to help Kroki.
So I can trap my land back.
Alright.
Eventually.
We'll grab the rest.
We'll kill the squatters.
Also.
After I grab my land.
Give me power so I can kill in my land.
Because apparently I can't attack people in Doki world.
Even though I own Doki world.
I own...
I own Doki world but for some reason it's not letting me kill people in my world.
Alright.
Let me know.
Let me know when it's been done.
The Emperor wasn't.
Wait.
Proof!
Okay.
You guys want proof?
Here you go.
Watch this.
Alright.
Doki world of Doki Birdo.
That's...
That's a lie.
How many land does he have?
How much land does he have?
Unwhitelist.
Unwhitelist him.
Right now.
Kick him out.
I'm kicking.
Alright.
Unclaim his land.
Take him a while to get back in.
She's going mad now.
So...
Alright.
Bro's gonna wait 10 hours in the void.
Let me know.
If it keeps escalating.
They knew the risk.
How do you claim the land already?
The Doki SMP situation is crazy.
How does everyone...
Keep...
Okay.
I'm gonna wait till you're asleep.
Then...
You'll be the last person who owns Doki Land.
And when you log off, it's over for you.
Alright.
That's so cute.
Okay.
Alright.
We'll figure this out later.
We'll figure out this later.
Alright.
Okay.
So.
Um.
Silent Croaky.
Why can't I kill people on my land?
Fix this.
Right now.
Fix this right now.
I renamed.
That is not true.
That...
I am track.
That is not true.
That's great.
Why can't I kill people?
This is my land.
What is this?
No.
If you own the land, you can hit other people.
In your own land.
So.
I should be allowed...
To attack players.
In my own land.
But I can't for some reason.
So I'm trying to figure this out.
The moment.
A moment.
The moment I- Wait.
Why can't I hit my own mod?
I- I can hit my own mod!berty!
Wait.
Where is he?
I'm mad.
Why can I do anything?
Why can't I kill my people?
Why?
Oh shit.
That's right!
If I can kill Thanos, I will do it to you, too!
I don't know why I can't find a piece...
TP...
Wait, how did I die?
Justice...
Not even mods are safe...
Wait, why can't I...
Oh, teleport.
Where's my stuff?
Where did I die?
Why were they able to get my stuff?
My stuff!
Who was it?
Who took my stuff?
Who took it?
Who took my things?
Who took my stuff?
Oh my god, there's so many squatters now!
There's so many squatters!
What do you mean?
That's it!
Wipe everybody's inventory!
Wipe everyone's inventory now!
Now that... Wipe... everyone's inventory.
That's right.
That's right!
Everyone's inventory!
Gone!
All right!
That's right!
Everyone gets punished!
Everyone gets punished now!
Wait, the Wipe!
We all suffer!
That's right!
You did this!
Now I'm stranded!
That's right!
Nobody fucks with me!
Guilty by association!
That's right!
Have you all learned your lesson now?
Have you?
Oh, shit!
The BBC back to throw key world!
Wait, my claim!
Oh, shit!
Also, give us all our claim items!
We don't have claim items anymore!
Guys, we don't have...
Guys, we can't claim anything!
Wait!
This is not a throw key!
Give us our...
At least give us our claim items!
Give us our claim items!
You robbed me of my own!
Not nice if I get none of...
Okay, maybe we shouldn't have, like, wiped everything all at once!
This was a little...
Oopsie!
Alright, so I think that's a good time!
That's a good time to call it!
Well, that's not a croaky fix this mess!
Well, we'll let him fix everything!
We'll let him fix it all!
We'll...
I'll let him fix it!
I'll...
Anyway, guys!
I hope you guys had a lot of fun on the...
On the Doki SMP!
Uh...
I mean...
And then just leave...
I'll be back!
I'll be...
I'll be back, guys!
I'll see you next month!
I'll see you...
Hahaha!
But...
Um...
I ha...
I hope you guys had a wonderful time playing with me today!
If you also wanna...
If you wanna join in...
Um...
The new and improved SMP!
If you guys wanna have some fun and play some more at the SMP!
Uh...
Remember to just join the membership!
Join the membership!
And...
Um...
And follow the instructions and everything!
And also we have our game jam!
I hope everyone has fun at the game jam!
I'm super excited, guys!
Uh...
The new and improved Doki SMP!
If you guys have any other suggestions on how to improve it or things you wanna see, um, for future updates, feel free to join the Discord server!
Well, you have to join the Discord server to even, like, you know, uh, to join the Discord server to, like, um, access the Minecraft server!
So, yeah!
Put your suggestions in the server, uh, for any, like, quality of life changes you want, any future updates, any fun things you wanna add, any plugins and everything!
Um, but anyway, guys, as always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check, get up and move around to get that blood flowing!
Like, if you stay up for me, head to bed, cause, you deserve it!
I'll see you guys next time, everybody!
Bye, guys!
Bye!